and so when you stepped in uh i
actually remember this uh there was a
huge focus on historically
pension managers have essentially gone
out found the best asset managers
you know in the world uh and they give
them the money and there's all these
questions about
fees and structure and risk they're
taking and kind of all the things that
come
with who are we giving our money to and
you know what's the probability that
they're going to give us back a great
return
you took a very different approach uh
and one that i think now has become
uh one replicated in other places uh but
two also more and more people are
starting to say wait a second
like that may be something that makes a
lot of sense so let's talk through just
kind of at a high level like what the
philosophy of the invest
investment strategy is and then we can
get into some more of the tactical
things that you guys did
awesome okay um
so here's the philosophy is
for starters so pensions allocate asset
right
we we have an ad you know an asset
allocation to
exactly what you expect right to stocks
bonds real estate
uh other you know some pensions might
have commodities might have diversifying
strategies i mean also there's all
different
things and then of course there's
subclasses within those okay
the um now within so so that's kind of
the top of the stack let's say
are the are the asset classes then sub
asset classes and how do you get those
invested
most pensions allocate
invest that money which we'll call
allocating okay
um invest that money through third-party
managers
that is smart that is a smart way to do
it okay
that is smart if i didn't mention it
three times already
um what you i you don't want to build
some big investment team
to be picking stocks finding private
equity investments
god help you pensions have done all
right
in direct investing in real estate um
and i saw you had a tweet last night
someone said let's talk about real
estate absolutely in a little bit
um when we're drilling down they've done
okay in that and there's a sort of
limited kind of trouble you can get in
let's say with real estate
um unless the brother-in-law one of the
trustees uh
right is a developer and you know you're
laughing
pal i'm laughing because i've read the
stories i know what happens
so but like when so so when you took
over right there's 24
or 18 to 24 billion dollars somewhere in
there uh you guys are actually
not doing well third third percent or
quartile of
performance and you basically from what
i understand walked in and just started
saying look
let's get into kind of a just start
slashing fees make sure that we're not
spending a bunch of money to
actually get our capital invested and
then you took this kind of disciplined
systematic approach that was really
focused on innovation so kind of explain
what that means when you say a
disciplined systematic approach
with an overweight or focus on kind of
technology and innovation
got it got it okay so um
so the portfolio that i inherited
um had two 300 managers
across right so no po could you imagine
like
it and by the way it was volunteer um so
uh i was
willing to really kind of get in i was
gonna be you know i was
soon to be elected chairman and but i
mean what are you gonna do with two or
three hundred you can't possibly wrap
your arms around it and really we should
be focusing on
the top of the stack on allocation um
and
so right away you know i often say i had
no preconceived notions
on things like hedge funds private
equity credit you know
opportunistic credit real estate etc um
but i did have a preconceived notion
that a sh
you want to simplify you want to be able
to understand what the hell it is you
have
right you have board meetings quarterly
we
might maybe you'll have six a year right
so um and you got a lot to do in them
and you've got a limited staff so
you want to simplify and
it's fine in a million so i love
indexing i index about half my half my
own assets
the beautiful thing about indexing is
once you
you take that allocation to top of the
stack i was telling you about you know
public market equities domestic right
domestic internationally
right if you who index there's nothing
to do like you're done
you don't need a staff you don't need
you know the board doesn't need to
discuss it you are going to get the
market return
right and there's all this attacking of
you know that it's you know
terrible and you end up owning a bunch
of stuff you know i mean look at the
assets that to this day
are the concentrations in the s p 500 so
which again we can get to a little bit
later as i sort of go through your
questions so
so index is what i didn't realize though
is i had no idea so all pensions
pensions operate around around the
government right they're funded by
governments
you know the state pension which is mo
most of the pension assets
um anytime you have government around
you're going to politics around
and um early on like i
got it's unbelievable i'm driving
somewhere i get a call
and i don't recognize the number but
it's a lobbyist
it's a lobbyist calling me about some
manager that they hear that we're going
to be you know reduce
shortening the you know simplifying the
manager roster and um
i'm like do you realize you're calling
me is
a material piece of data right that will
support getting rid of your whoever
you're calling me about
please don't tell me the name like are
you kidding me
like i mean that happened and that by
the way happened more than once
um and um so i was uh i
i was fortunate in that i had
you know the governor governor's staff
were super supportive of what
kind of whatever it is i did i think and
so
as soon as those calls went in over
there they're like deal with mark
it's a brick wall okay and it feels like
um as you step in as the chairman like
really
you said it already right like the goal
is do we get the asset allocation right
meaning we're going to take 10 put in
real estate we're going to put you know
60
in stocks we're going to put in you know
here's how we break it down across all
the different indices whatever it ends
up being
most people will then spend tons and
tons of time on well which manager do we
select
within this bucket well you're basically
making the argument for
and you guys did was you basically said
look
if most of people aren't going to beat
the industry benchmark
then why don't we just invest in the
industry benchmark and therefore yes
there might be one or two people who
beat it
but we're gonna beat eighty ninety
percent of the managers in this space
anyways by just investing in the
benchmark
it's easier we just buy it we don't have
to go and check on a manager do all that
kind of stuff
and then also it's usually much cheaper
on top of that right
there's a and there's an additional
advantage which is so
the the meeting that i was elected
chairman of we
terminated so there were four managers
out of the hundreds that were on
watch so i'm like surely if we have like
200 magic we can
we can at least terminate the four that
are on watch and have been on watch for
a year
for or more than a year so um so sure
enough of course the media was there
and there was a you know our articles
were later yadda yadda which i think
actually
to me they they i think started out as
hit pieces i think they made us look
terrific
um but here's what i noticed though so
in the investment committee meeting when
we were
really getting into the guts of this
one of the trustees on the other side
table i mean got pretty pissed of like
you know you're
you know we got an rfp for general
consultant because which was kind of
part of all of this
um and uh you're terminating these
matters like
you know and got really pissed and i
could see this is kind of thing that i
think
happens over and over often happens
behind closed doors maybe with a staffer
okay who needs a board to like that
anyway once
sort of people chilled a little bit then
we had board meeting and
same kind of you know kind of energy
entered the room lots of heat
and then and so one point they the vote
was going to be the vote the vote ended
up being six to three
um and eight to one actually on a couple
determinations
so this trustee sits fine sits down it's
like all right mark
what are you putting the money into and
uh like
it's going to be indexed and all the
heat came out of the room
and that's what gave me the idea to
write that first wall street journal
op-ed
all like it indexing not only is a
terrific way to invest
okay it also is a beautiful beautiful
governance tool
to keep people out of trouble okay like
just recently that north carolina
senator you know
or georgia wherever they are um and you
know this has happened kind of over and
over
where right it's like if you index no
you're you so
you really become impenetrable from the
peanut gallery shooting at you and in
this case
where's the manager getting terminated
and by the way the manager perfectly
good people doing a professional job i
never once suggested that wasn't the
case and it wasn't the case
they were just kind of a little under
their benchmark at best they'd be at
their benchmark
and i'm just trying to simplify things
and that's where our board ended up
and um and so by index then you take the
insult out of it
and and the other piece of this pump is
and actually some so there's a a
professor actually he's in arizona state
um sunil warhol who i quoted a couple of
times and
some of them so my materials has done
great great academic research
which i kind of got obsessed with on
institutional investor decisions by the
way this is not just pensions this is
endowments foundations
everyone suffers from this of you're
constantly
firing managers and hiring other ones
okay
flavor of the month all right and so
it's like beautiful academic research
that
in like 80 90 of the cases the manager
you replace
that came in is kind of underperforming
their benchmark as
you know within sort of a year or two uh
and you're just running on a treadmill
you're wasting your time